and I know now and you're obviously
happily married so what like how petty
do arguments get in your house it's
usually me and it's usually because I'm
hungry so we have a lot of hangry fights
and one time I picked a fight with him
to be fair it was during like day three
of my extreme weight loss diet for
Leamas and I picked a fight with him
about a sunset like whether it was
pretty or not no no okay so I the early
days of the weight loss I was a little
manic and I I went outside and I was
like I was feeling things pretty
intensely and I saw the sunset I was
like oh my god it's the most beautiful
sons that I've ever seen come on as I
ran inside and my husband
who is being so nice and like holding my
hand through this you know I kid of the
early days of this is pretty hard he's
been so nice he's literally he's like I
need to have a 15-minute work called
one point during the day and I burst
inside I'm like honey there's a sunset
outside we have to go and I just soaked
immediately pull is soaked and I'm
sitting there I'm like well it's it's
happening right now we're gonna miss it
and then he is like okay I just need
five minutes bait and I think it and
it's a and it's a work call and I'm
sitting there and I make it about 30
seconds my patience is not there and I
finally I stand up I'm like okay you
know he's on a work call and I'm like
okay I'm going outside you can come find
me I'm really bad and so then and the
thing is were at a hotel which is on
like 100 acre estate like the front yard
is 20 acres and the backyard is 80 acres
and he's like well okay um he's so sweet
he's like okay sweetie I'll come find
you where will you be
and I go I'm not in the front I'll be in
the back and then I hid behind a statue
and stuck my foot out and got mad and he
couldn't find me
[Music]
you